all right so how many how many of you in
the room are react developers like you
do react on a regular mail
so how many of you are angular
developers okay I'm gonna tell you right
now that the vast majority of what I
talk about today is applicable directly
on the angular side to its it's called
progressive web apps with react only
because the application I'm using
happens to be in react but like past the
first three minutes of the talk it's
applicable across the board or whatever
you want to do um okay how many of you
actively build progressive web apps
right now I've got three okay and I have
to remember who because when my demo
breaks eventually I have to know who I
can point to that can help me out so you
know what you just signed up for it by
raising your hand okay
so my name is John I'm JavaScript guy I
do a lot of react stuff I'm also a
plural slide author how many of you do
Pluralsight if you do not actively have
a plural side subscription let me know
I've got like 30 day trial cards that
I'm happy to give out and you can play
around with okay so I am also from here
which I'm more specifically from right
here like in the middle because normally
when I say I'm from the States people
assume I'm either from here or from here
and they forget or don't realize that
there's like this big massive expanse in
the middle so I'm like as far from
either of those spots as I could
possibly get but thank you for having me
out here I've I've been in Lithuania for
not even 24 hours and it's been pretty
awesome so I appreciate it alright here
we go we're gonna get started we're at a
conference I don't know if you guys
realize this but I'm filling you in now
if you were to late at the sky bar last
night like you're here how many of you
have looked at
this today right most because you got to
know where to go next right and chances
are that when you walk out of the room
you're gonna look at this again because
now you have to pick one of these talks
to go to right so I go to a lot of
conferences and the struggle sometimes
now I'm not very familiar yet with this
event you guys might be more fortunate
than you think it's often times when I
go to get this I end up getting the
dinosaur game how many of you play the
dinosaur game right how many of you have
no idea what I'm talking about about
like a game
okay so we'll come back to the dinosaur
game in a minute but right but but I
want the dinosaur game I I want the
schedule right and so one of the
problems we have with a webpage and this
is gonna sound weird when I say it and I
understand that one of the problems we
have with a webpage is that the webpage
doesn't work when you're not connected
to the Internet
right so let that sink in for just a
second that seems very obvious but at
the same time that's a problem huh and
so we have all kinds of ways of fixing
that one of them being you gonna have an
app that you now have to get installed
in the App Store and you download it and
you do all of that stuff or or you hand
out paper that's equally an option um
but then I lose it immediately and now I
have no way of getting that back so one
of the problems that a progressive web
app is trying to solve is this and so
what I'm gonna focus on today because I
only have 45 minutes now is we're gonna
focus mostly on this problem I'm gonna
show you a bunch of other stuff we're
gonna focus mostly on this how can I
make my web page work when I don't have
internet access oh okay so progressive
web apps solve this problem okay
so there's there's a couple of things
that define a progressive web app I'm
gonna talk about this real quick and
then we're gonna like do some code so
progressive web apps ultimately need to
be reliable which means when you're not
online they still work which is still
weird to me um they need to be fast I'm
not going to talk as much about this but
the idea is there is a lot of people who
are not on broad bands like LTE type
internet a lot of people still are on
dial-up or they want you want your app
to be as fast as possible which means
like don't download a three Meg's AS
bundle in order to start your
application things like that engaging so
let me ask you a question this sitting
right in front of me is a laptop and you
know this I assume but I have a laptop
right here how many of you when you go
to to get on a webpage prefer to use
this over the laptop right I generally
do it I'm actually kind of weird even
when I'm at work I'm sitting in front of
a laptop with two screens and I will
stop what I'm doing I'll pull my phone
out and I'll get a Google it whatever on
my phone just because I don't know I'm
weird so what what this means is your
websites your your thing needs to work
as well here as it does here okay so
let's talk about some of the firm a
second I'm going to show you a couple
things
all right so I have a web application
and I'm going to walk you through those
of you who don't know reactive it's
gonna walk you through it real quick
and then we're gonna demo it and we're
gonna play around so if you can't read
this well I can't really fix it any more
that I have so I'm sorry uh also yeah
I tend to talk really fast when I get
going and so any moment just like yell
at me and say slow down or ask me
questions either way it's fine okay so I
have in this application an index dot
HTML that basically has nothing in it as
this
and what this means is that I'm gonna
pull down a script and I'm going to
inject my app into my route you don't
need to worry about much more than that
okay so I have a very very simple app
and the reason I have a very simple app
is because we want to focus on
implementing a progressive web app not
all of the the complication of a very
complicated web application so this is
very simple I have a constructor what I
load it up I add to my state this empty
array there's nothing in the array
whatsoever when I click a button I'm
going to do an axial who knows at what
axis okay excellent if you don't know
what axis axis is just a package that is
used to go download stuff over HTTP like
it's it's the replacement for fetch or
or whatever so actually just again I'm
gonna go pull some date some some data
from a JSON file and I'm going to add it
to books after adding a second just so
that you can otherwise it happens too
fast and then everybody misses and I'm
gonna render a thing we're still in
react we have this weird thing actually
I guess angular does it where all of our
code is like in one file which you can
like or hate I don't care but we've got
all our JavaScript and all of our HTML
all like mixed together which I used to
hate now just used to it so it's fine oh
I just I just gave in eventually and
said that's the way the world works now
so so I've got my HTML library and then
I loop over books I spit out the title
the author the genre done all right
so I already have it running so I'm
gonna go over to my website and look how
I have this thing what's gonna happen
when I click refresh
I'm even gonna get books thank you Bill
there we go that's all it is okay that
is the entire application so the vast
majority of this talk is gonna Center on
this thing down here how many of you on
a daily basis use chrome dev tools okay
excellent that is the right answer by
the way how many of you have ever
ventured past the third tab right okay a
lot of excellence so I'm gonna send
spend quite a bit of time talking about
like stuff over here because a lot of
people don't play around with a lot of
the stuff over here and that's the main
point of what we're gonna do the console
is obvious right all of this stuff so I
have a very simple web application that
does very simple things but yet when I
click this button right here my whole
browser is now offline and I'm gonna hit
refresh and what's gonna happen no no
close not yes
spoiler alert that's coming so I write I
get loading and then I get nothing
because down here at the bottom it tries
to go get data Dutch JSON and it fails
what happens now it's your big moment
what happens when I hit refresh up here
now in fairness I call them both the
same thing I can understand the
confusion
okay I get the dinosaur game now with
the dinosaur game basically is have you
ever played flappy bird right that's the
idea right you just try and jump over
the little cactuses as they come through
I have a twelve-year-old son who has a
Playstation and an Xbox and an iPhone
that has lots of games on it and he will
turn off his Wi-Fi on his laptop so he
can play the dinosaur game but anyway so
right and for some reason my Chrome
browser started doing this
I don't but I don't care so I'm gonna go
back online I'm gonna hit refresh and of
course what if I do that 3,000 all right
in spots boom all right hopefully I
won't have to do that like over and over
and over again where was that Network
okay so none of this should surprise you
that's like how the internet works right
you go offline
nothing functions done so we're gonna
talk progressive web apps to kind of fix
that problem we're gonna come all the
way down to the audits tab now how many
of you have heard of lighthouse so
lighthouse many of you excellent
lighthouse was a tool but I use the term
was a tool that was a plug-in to Chrome
that would audit your website for you it
is no longer called lighthouse it is no
longer a plug-in into Chrome it has now
built in and the only reason I say any
of that is because when you click on
audits you get a lighthouse icon that
would make no sense whatsoever if you
didn't know that it used to be called
lighthouse and so what audits does for
you is this is a very cool tool and you
should be using it regardless of whether
you're doing progressive web apps or not
it will look at your website and it will
tell you whether or not you are using
best practices
it'll audit your SEO audits
accessibility it does all kinds of stuff
for you that otherwise might not be done
we are going to focus today on the
progressive web app piece and so I'm
gonna click run on it and what run on it
the first thing running on its gonna do
is it's going to change me to a iPhone
or a pixel 2 or whatever and so if you
don't know you can do this you can
change your device types up here and so
that you can see how it will work on
different devices ok turn that off so
I'm going to click audit I wanna see
what happens if she's gonna do a whole
bunch of stuff you'll see the dinosaur
game flash up here for a second and then
you need to enable job
scripted I'm gonna come back with a
score of 50 which may is not zero for
the record I have a son who's in college
no 50 still bad even for that um okay so
so okay let's look at the stuff that
passed and then I'll tell you what
failed okay
page load is fast enough on 3G I
seriously hope so considering the size
of the application that we're talking
about if it didn't put fast on 3G we
have problems but page load is fast
enough on 3G ultimately that's something
for a real application you want to look
at we do use HTTPS which is great I
didn't really do anything to make that
happen but the local host thing just
kind of does it for me
contains some content when javascript is
not available I need to ask this
question because this will be important
in a minute do I have any like security
professionals in the room anybody who
does like security or you're so secure
you don't want to tell me but that's
what you do I can't have one I thought I
saw your hand but I was looking at the
road okay I have one guy sometimes
people actually navigate the web with
JavaScript turned off because I don't
know if you know this the web is not a
safe place and so we we try and and so
what you want is your website to do
something when javascript is turned off
now what is ours do because I didn't
really talk about that if I go back to
index dot HTML look at this that's all I
do
you needed a medical JavaScript to run
this out done one thing that might make
sense if you're building like a schedule
or something is you can just put a
hard-coded version of it up here and
let's say if you want the actual website
turn javascript up so it'll let you know
if you're doing that and then content is
size correctly I'm not going to talk too
much about the responsiveness that's
that's gonna come down into this it's
going to change the size and see if it
moves stuff around who uses a bootstrap
okay who what other packet there's
all kinds of so the responsive side of
this we've been talking about for years
right and so I'm not as concerned with
making your website responsive use a
thing like boot shop or something it's
kind of does it for you let's look at
the stuff that failed now if I haven't
if I hadn't given you the opening like
the introduction this first one looks
dumb does not respond when a201 offline
a website should never respond with a
200 when you're offline because 200
means it works like I asked for data
I got data it shouldn't do that when
you're offline right and then let's look
at number four does not register a
serviceworker so let's talk about this
because this is ultimately the vast
majority of of what we're gonna talk
about does that register serviceworker
does not respond with 200 when offline
let's talk serviceworkers ok important
question
who knows what a web worker is many of
you so a web worker I'm not going to
call on you I'm just gonna I should I'm
not going to ok a web worker I will call
on people in a minute a web worker is is
something that you can spin up over
beside your web page and will execute
stuff very simply that's essentially
what it is if you're interested in
things like web workers and Atomics and
things like that
Jeffrey Strauss is giving a talk on
multi-threaded JavaScript later he'll
dig into this because this is not what
we're talking about so service workers
are not web workers but the basic like
the very basic idea is similar service
worker is something that sits over here
and does some stuff outside of your
brother here's the scary thing so a
security guy tell me if this sounds
horrible to you we're going to install
something that's going to hijack all of
the HTTP traffic coming out of the
browser for this web page and it's going
to do whatever it wants with it I could
request something and it could say no
I'm gonna go get this other thing over
here instead pull it in and send it back
to the web page as if it was the thing I
asked for
I could post my user name and password
and the service worker could say hey
that's awesome I'm going to send that
information over here and over here all
of these types of things so so service
workers are are scary but yet the only
way this whole thing works so we kind of
have to work in the middle so one of the
requirements you'll notice one of the
requirements we passed is progressive
web apps must and must is a suggestion
it's not enforced but it should be must
use HTTPS and part of the reason for
that you're nodding your head so you're
in agreement on this the reason for that
is you don't want one of these being
messed with ultimately okay so the way
the way service workers work there's two
pieces of code and we'll talk through
them and then I'll show it to you so the
first one is in your index that HTML you
need to register your service worker and
the first thing that might be a red flag
so bill pay attention if service worker
is a navigator I'm gonna register a
service worker which means that if
you're on a slightly older browser this
isn't gonna work at all immediately off
the bat we're not gonna have to be able
to do this
so if service worker happens we're gonna
register it it's gonna go pull our
service worker which we've called
offline j/s and then we're gonna
register it it's got to be ready it's
gonna be great we're going to install
this we just saw the first thing we do
when we installed check this out and
then open the cache and I'm going to go
pull a bunch of stuff very first thing
I'm gonna pull index.html my bundle and
my data JSON and I'm gonna cash it right
away and then the important part of this
whole thing is a piece of code that says
hey whenever a fetch happens every time
a fetch happens I'm gonna do something
other than the fetch
so I'm gonna check and if I have a cache
if it's already cash I'm just gonna
return my response otherwise I'm gonna
do the fetch turn response otherwise I'm
gonna do the fetch and then I'm going to
cash it
that's a serviceworker okay
let's play with this OOP do
okay so if I go to offline yes what
you'll see there's all the stuff we just
talked about I've got like build stuff
it's my cache name and we'll look at
that in a second and then I'm gonna go
do a whole bunch of things let's come
back over here look at what just
happened because it refreshed
automatically because that's what
happens down here at the bottom I've
installed the serviceworker I've
activated the serviceworker it's ready
it's registered so I'm gonna refresh my
page and it worked which is should not
be a surprise to you hold on I'm going
to do it again so you guys can see this
clear refresh okay because yeah so
notice when I first refresh my page if
those of you who are behind this podium
which is very poorly placed for this
particular demo you'll see four things
offline j/s index HTML data JSON and
bundles a yes and they have a little
icon next to them a little gear and what
that means what the little gear means is
the serviceworker
went and got that so immediately you can
see the difference now when I hit
refresh notice Dana JSON came back I
went and got data dot JSON if you look
all the way over here from serviceworker
so there's no sighs there's no nothing
it just said hey the serviceworker just
sent it back to you which is great
because when I click offline like this
what's going to happen when I click this
button
so worked what happened last time I
clicked the button
nothing worked right what happens when I
hit refresh so I'll pull this up I'm
gonna hit refresh
of course because my thing crashed it
didn't crash what in the world
hold on it is and I've done this twice
this week already
and it always ok inspect Network refresh
yay I click off line I hit refresh it
goes and gets my stuff I hit refresh and
it worked ok just turn it off turn it
back on again everything works but so
right we'll get we'll get to the whole
whether you should actively be using
progressive web apps in a minute but
notice localhost this is what should
have happened a minute ago localhost is
right here came back from serviceworker
because we cached
index.html so now I'm scared to do this
but I'm gonna do it anyway I'm gonna
close my browser I'm gonna open it again
I'm gonna hit that I'm gonna go and it
still works hold on I'm gonna open a new
window I'm going to inspect I'm gonna go
offline first I'm gonna paste it and it
still works so this is where it becomes
a little scary or awesome depending on
who you are because the serviceworker
when i close my browser didn't go
anywhere right it stayed there and it
will stay there for ever and so every
time I go to localhost 3000 and that
serviceworker is there that
serviceworker is doing its thing and
it's going to return back
anything that it has cached so let's
look at what it has cached so back over
to the application tab so I so
serviceworker first of all is right here
i have service workers registered so
anytime you can go out to your
application tab and you can see whether
a website has a service worker
registered and you can click on offline
j/s and it'll show you the code for the
service worker the other thing that is
here is you can come down to the cache
storage down here at the bottom and
there's a there's a build stuff cache
and I'm gonna click on that and then
you'll see all of the stuff so there's
my data JSON my index.html everything
that's cached and stored there and then
I can click in data a JSON and see
there's my stuff ok excellent what
happens when I come back on no stop it I
hit refresh everything works what
happens when I come back over to my code
I go into dated JSON and I change this
to just war I changed my data what's
gonna happen when I hit refresh it's
still warm peace so this is a problem
that we'll talk about here in just a
minute
because what am i doing I'm cashing
everything and I never go check again
which is probably not the best way to do
it but it's easier to demo that way so
that you understand what's going on I
will fix that in just a second but first
Oh hold on before I do the thing that
I'm about to do I'm gonna go back to
audit and I'm gonna run it on it again
it's doing all this stuff notice you
didn't get the dinosaur game this time
I'm at 73% now unlike the 50% my son who
is in college will attempt to tell me
that 73% is fine because 73% is a
passing grade at least for us it is um
so it's it's not a great passing grade
but it passes this is not enough good
enough for us notice it's yellow and not
green so let's look at what is failing
now user will not be prompted to install
the web application so here's the other
thing about progressive web apps it's
one thing to say when I go to my browser
I pull up the schedule and I go to the
the schedule page it works every time
but I still have to pull up the browser
right I don't want to have to pull up
the browser I want this thing on my
desktop so I can just click on it it's
going to come up it's going to work so
that's what the so notice it says no
manifest was fetched
so manifest is manifest is broken so
let's talk about a manifest okay so
somebody tell me without talking about
technology at all
what is a manifest like what is what
does the word mean or where would you
use that word
I'm curious actually I'm curious
politics shipping logistics is what
what's the Lithuanian word for men okay
so it's pretty much the same thing right
because it was funny I was in I was in
Bulgaria two days ago
doing this talk and and I asked the same
quiet because I asked what a manifest
was and everybody kind of just looked at
me and I said I don't know what the
Bulgarian word is for and they're like
it's manifest um so so it's the same
right so it's it's very close this
manifest us is that what you said okay
excellent I know one Lithuanian word you
guys heard it I'll learn more over the
course of the next 24 hours but I have
one down so shipping and logistics right
so ultimately when you're shipping
something you have you have a manifest
that gives details about what that
shipment is is that is that fair you
agree with that it's the same thing here
all a manifest is is basically something
that the browser can take and it tells
it a little bit about the application so
that it could use it appropriately so a
manifest describes your web page in an
application context so it basically
describes a web page as an application
like if we were going to make an
application out of this we're gonna in
our index.html you even have like a like
where you would normally have like
stylesheet here manifest and we're gonna
install the manifest okay basically it's
just hey if this was an application here
would be the short name for it library
here would be the the colors here's the
startup URL index
that HTML so when when you load this
thing just navigate to end I say HTML or
wherever it is we want to go so let's
look at that with any luck it'll work
and I won't have broken everything okay
so I'm gonna go to application and I'm
gonna click on manifest and I'm gonna
hit refresh and it still isn't there uh
am i I'm not offline but it's still not
there why is it still out there yes
it's cached remember I have a service
worker that's cached everything and when
I update things it won't let me go fix
it right so the first thing I have to do
there's two things we can do here and go
to service workers that I can unregister
a service worker so back over in my in
my application tab I can unregister it
what I generally like to do is there's
there's a clear storage where I can just
like scroll down to the bottom and just
say get rid of everything and then I'm
gonna refresh I got a new service worker
this is hate it today okay
it's alright we'll be fine I'm gonna go
back to my application
there's my manifest I'm gonna save it
but I've come here I'm gonna cancel that
I'm gonna npm start it and it's gonna
work and then I'm gonna go back to my
serviceworker I'm gonna unregister it
I'm gonna refresh and now I have a
manifest okay it's just sometimes it
takes a second which is part of part of
the point okay build stuff library demo
is the name index of HTML I've got some
colors I also now have a link over here
on the right side of my page that says
add to homescreen which is going how
many of you have apps installed in
Chrome right so if I come here and I go
to apps I have apps I've got postman and
I've got some other things installed
TweetDeck if I click Add to Home screen
it's gonna say hey do you want to use it
at any time I'm gonna click Add
I'm gonna click create notice I've got
an icon that was described in the
manifest I'm pointing in my laptop
screen that doesn't help you described
in the manifest right here I've got an
icon notice the icon is the same and I'm
going to click create and now it's going
to sit here in my apps and so it takes
whatever's in the manifest to generate
some app out of it and drops it here so
it does that all automatically now what
this means is if I double click on this
I have an app that's that's there
forever okay let's run one more audit
and then we're gonna conduct a social
experiment because Bill has to report
back to his boss on something and I want
to give him some information he can use
so 92 yes it is green now and I am
comfortable with that the only thing I'm
not comfortable with is the error so if
my son back to my son if he came home
and he said 92 is a perfectly acceptable
grade I yes I can't argue with that um
does not redirect HTTP traffic to HTTPS
so I'm not redirecting I don't care
about that so much for a demo redirect
to HTTPS so one thing we want to do is
to finish this out we're going to deploy
this
so how many of you use oh so this whole
thing is out on github PR DCP WI that's
out here on github you can play with it
you can get to it I will I'll tweet out
my slides and then you can you can get
to it so there's a thing called github
pages how many of you have heard of
github pages so github pages is a
package excellent so I'm not going to
talk about it at all except that I will
tell you this yeah hub pages is that is
a package that will take your github
repository and publish it out to pages
to our github that IO / what I not pages
Jonathan F mill so my github dot io
slash whatever my repository is so we
kind of install it one thing you have to
change I'm just gonna tell you this and
you can google it later I have to set my
homepage and then I have to set the
framework for for my serviceworker but
here is a QR code and a website on your
phone go to this webpage and tell me
what don't play around with it too much
yet tell me social experiment for Bill
how many of you are prompted to install
to your desktop okay I have
- there will be some of you I just for
the record those of you who do not get
prompted there are people who aren't
raising their hands so it did work who
did not get prompted to install it what
kind of phone do you have what kind of
phone do you have okay
iPhone iPhone so I've got a couple of
androids that it didn't do it on and
I've got a did anybody have an iPhone
that worked did you catch that there are
no iPhones that work okay if you're on
an iPhone I'm not lying to you go to of
all places share Add to Home screen
makes no sense at all why it would be
under share but if you go to share Add
to Home screen
it'll add it to your home screen also
now that you've all done it quick
security tip never take something that
some random guy puts up on a screen that
says install this to your desktop with
no security of a half the story at all
anybody have a Microsoft phone I don't
know if you guys know this but Microsoft
makes phones this will never work
Microsoft so you can imagine here's I
mean this is a very serious thing if you
can install apps to your desktop or to
your phone this way how does Apple make
a lot of their money the App Store so
does Google so does Microsoft well no
Microsoft makes a little bit of money
through their app store they are very
resistant to this they're finally coming
around and they're finally allowing it
by hiding it in the share menu but it's
there and so there's some resistance on
the part of the the app stores to allow
this kind of functionality to happen
okay I promised you because
I have 12 minutes that we would do one
more thing I'm gonna go back to my
offline ojs okay here's how offline
works I'm cashing everything and then I
say hey if my cash matches then I'm
gonna send the response back let's do
this let's comment that out I'm not to
come down here to my fetch so here I've
got my fetch
if fetch crashes I'm gonna catch it and
then I'm gonna return my cash response
fair
okay I'm gonna save this I'm gonna come
back over and I'm gonna tell you it will
work after I clear everything out I'm
gonna hit refresh let me go to my
service workers I'm going to go to
offline Jay yes and it's commented out
so it worked
okay I'm gonna hit refresh here I get my
stuff I'm gonna go offline I'm gonna
refresh okay wait before I do that
notice down at the bottom I'm just going
to describe it to you way at the bottom
well here let me do it again so it's up
higher oh I went offline okay so I have
a data JSON from service worker but
notice I have another one because
service worker returned it but it also
then went and got it so now this is
behavior we didn't see before and so if
I go back to my vs code here I have just
war if I go back to my data JSON and I
say and peace I save it I hit refresh
now I get the whole thing so now it
works if I go offline and I
refresh it still works if I change it
offline it didn't work why because it
cashed it right but the minute I come
back online now it updates so that's
more in line without yes right there are
packages out there that you can use
especially if you use well right so
there's packages out there I don't want
to get that will do a lot of this stuff
create react up if you do react to use a
trait react up if you use react and do
not use create react out you should be
Facebook the like the people who do it
also use create react app so it's not
too good or you're not too good to use
it I started a new job and and the team
I was working with I asked if they use
create react up but there's no we're
beyond that I said no you're not I don't
know what to your point there's packages
that do this stuff use the packages that
do it okay but this is still new ish
enough that that I haven't found one
that I really like yet and and I want to
kind of go through the mechanics of it
but
[Music]
get from cashiers oh I haven't looked
into it too much for that specific use
case I would expect very rapidly a lot
of tooling to evolve around it as more
and more people do it the struggle still
right now is that as we saw it still
doesn't work for a lot of people and so
we're we're working through that process
not necessarily first but still that's
that's the problem I think most people
are still trying to work on ok
so okay so so basically all all we
talked about I'm gonna recap progressive
web apps are ultimately in this use case
we want this stuff to work when it's
offline service workers do that the
manifest stuff isn't quite there yet but
the service workers work for everybody
like having your thing work offline just
works the the manifest stuff isn't there
yet guys we saw iPhones trying to hide
it
it only didn't you had an sa-7 somebody
had an s7 that I would have expected to
work and it didn't work not all the
browser's support it so that's an area
that's still a struggle and we're not
quite there yet
but we are we are rapidly making
progress
so okay questions any last minute yes
well okay so when you're doing if I
understand the question appropriately
progressive web apps have a fairly
narrow use case because the reality is
when my is my anyway I was going to show
you guys something the kind of response
to that but this is now what I'm getting
from Chrome but you can't see is it very
fairly narrow you see it because the
idea of caching results and things like
that doesn't always make sense
especially not if you're using like an
identity server something the
implication is you are online right if
you're not online you can't do a lot of
that stuff and so somebody asked me like
if they had a like a shopping card or
people could search things or it doesn't
make sense to cache those results
because they change every time you do
something or so so it still is a narrow
use case if if you want to dig into this
the the Google developers developers
double comm has a progressive web app
tutorial that I would love to show you
full screen but chrome hates me today oh
is it oh there we go yay that walks
through like all of this stuff and we'll
dig into a lot of a lot deeper than I
can get in in 50 minutes so okay I wanna
make sure we have time um if you have
yes one more question
okay so I feel like I do a lot but I
don't know what that means so go for it
I gotcha yeah yeah yeah yeah okay um so
yes because here's here's the other use
case for this so think about this I I
have a task application and I want to
complete tasks and and I'm building a
progressive web app which means I'm
gonna complete a task and I'm gonna do a
post but I'm offline so with a service
worker I can cache all that stuff and
then when I go back online I can send it
all which which means now it's kind of
even a little bit more where I can I can
do all kinds of stuff offline and
pretend that I'm online and then when
online comes back it builds out and I
don't know if that's exactly the same
thing that you're talking about if it's
not we can talk about it more but but
the service worker being able to cache
and then do more later becomes very very
useful when it comes to intermittent
internet so okay so that's it for me if
you have questions come talk to me
otherwise you guys are free to go have a
great rest of your bill stuff
[Applause]